[Music]
the next day the Serb leadership issues
an order that makes her greatest
situation even worse
we received the order that the army
should stop searching for the pilot so
we wouldn't be considered guilty of his
murder when he was captured by the
paramilitaries the hunt for the downed
pilot is left to the Serbian police the
paramilitaries and anyone with a gun but
although the terrain was under our
control there were many other groups
circulating around criminals operating
outside the sphere of the state
institutions and absolutely everyone had
weapons
rosco fears a bloodsucker personage they
are fun
swallows lady reckoners Menezes mr.
Barracuda leader buyer son Sean O'Grady
hasn't eaten since he left the base in
Italy two days ago he left his food
rations back at the landing site now he
faces a new threat hunger early didn't
start to feel no hungry
told after two days on the ground there
are no wild berries or fruit in survival
training yet leaves he runs through the
edibility test rub the plants on the
outside of your lip then on the inside
then hold it in your mouth for five
minutes then swallow at the first
unpleasant symptom send it back he
suffers no ill effects so he tries some
more they were just very dry and very
bitter and the grass was very coarse
with fiber
he cannot survive on leaves and grass
alone and digestion uses up water he's
down to his last three packs
he knows he's running out of time I was
dehydrated through the survival
situation consistently being awake never
slept at night took 20 minute after in
the daylight hours my heart's racing
like I'm running a marathon
your body's exhorting a great amount of
energy when you're you're cold and
you're wet and your sugaring trying to
stay warm
that night Oh Grady finally reaches a
hill to get to the top he must move
across open ground making himself an
easy target but he can't wait any longer
he has no choice but to take the risk
on the fourth day of combing the area
the Serbs think they've picked up a
Grady's trail we came across numerous
science in the woods which indicated to
us the presence of someone who was not
from our own forces suddenly O'Grady is
awoken by a sharp noise a farmer taking
his cows to a new pasture the smallest
movement could frighten the animal and
make the farmer curious if I was exposed
by cows handler he'd be able to tell
people that were then want to come and
get me
370 kilometers away pilots at the Aviano
base I'm not sure if though Grady is
alive there is always that doubt but we
would not accept that as far as brothers
in arms fire pilots we're gonna go out
and find him we're gonna bring him home
or we're gonna do everything we can to
do that his chance is a pretty damn slim
we probably would have heard something
by now everything tells us he is dead or
they got him but we got to keep looking
[Music]